what will happen if Joe Biden defeats
Donald Trump in November and then you
get a two-and-a-half or close to
three-month transitional period during
which Donald Trump is a very angry
lame-duck that's the first question
today in audience questions David what
do you believe the transition period
would look like if Donald Trump loses so
first of all I love the question and I'm
glad to explore it but let's not get
ahead of ourselves we first need to vote
and Joe Biden first needs to win before
we have to concern ourselves with what a
transition period would look like first
of all in the immediate I would imagine
a delayed concession I think that if it
is very very close on election night
Donald Trump will not concede and if it
is a blowout Donald Trump may also not
concede under the guise that it's too
obviously fake Trump couldn't possibly
have lost by so much so I think
regardless of the results there's a good
chance Trump does not concede now just a
reminder about concession concession is
legally meaningless concession is a
formality it's done to show good faith
to signal the beginning of a peaceful
transition of power and it's norms and
conventions and all that different stuff
but the the concession legally speaking
is not relevant it is true however that
if for example a Republican concedes you
may see Republican secretaries of state
who might get much more involved in
challenging results with recounts or
whatever maybe not do it so while
legally not significant concessions can
still signal to governors and
secretaries of state around the country
how should you react and what should you
do next
so Trump will in in all likelihood it's
if it's close and it's likely to be
close and Trump loses Trump will likely
say he was cheated or that it was rigged
we only have to look at 2016 remember in
2016 Trump won and he still to this day
insists that the results were false and
that it was rigged against him because
losing the popular vote did not
sufficient sufficiently placate Donald
Trump's massive ego you will probably
see a few Republicans who would support
Trump and claiming that it was rigged
but my belief is that most Republicans
are going to largely accept the results
if indeed Joe Biden wins then I wouldn't
be surprised if during the transition
period Trump doesn't invite Joe Biden to
the White House this is a completely
standard thing that's done the Bush's
invited the Obamas the Obamas invited
the Trump's I wouldn't be shocked at all
to see Donald Trump break with that
convention as well but then what really
matters about the transitional period is
going to be what does Donald Trump try
to do legislatively and via executive
order and in terms of judges and
appointments and nominations and what
does he actually get done because a
lame-duck Trump that is furious that he
lost and believes it was rigged or
claims it was rigged is going to be even
more brazen and even more unscrupulous
than we've seen him be I would expect a
ton of executive orders some legal some
not legal I would expect pardons that
benefit him or his interests in some
direct or indirect way and I would
expect a scaling up a vicious vicious
attacks against his political opponents
if Republicans controlled the house and
by the way this is why this is such an
important reason why the midterms
mattered so much when Democrats took the
house if Republicans controlled the
house you would have the risk of a
lame-duck Trump doing Wisconsin's style
legislation like when Scott Walker lost
the governorship in Wisconsin
Republicans in the legislature tried to
weaken the office of the governor for
the incoming Democrat to be able to do
much less if Republicans controlled the
house and Trump loses in November you
would likely see the same type of
attempt to limit the power of the office
of the presidency it's not going to
happen because Democrats took the house
in 2018 in terms of protests and
aftermath in terms of aftermath that
would include protests and unrest I do
think it depends on the margin of
victory I believe that a huge Biden
victory would set Trump off but that it
would really deflate the sales of the
Magga people a narrow victory by
I will more credibly let Trump claim it
was rigged and I would absolutely expect
militia types Patriot types etc to come
out and protest and there could be there
could certainly be violence and unrest I
do think that Mitch McConnell will keep
his eye on the ball and try to rapidly
get as many judges confirmed as possible
during a transition period for Trump
McConnell has been effective at doing
this legislation is unlikely again
because you need the house and the
democratically controlled house is not
going to give any big legislative
concessions to a lame-duck Trump that
they've just defeated so I would expect
a very messy November and December I
would expect lawsuits
maybe recounts and I don't think that
they will actually go anywhere if Joe
Biden wins over that transition period
media will start to ignore Trump more
and more and focus on who is going to be
in Biden's cabinet who from the from our
allies are coming back to the United
States and saying we welcome you we are
glad that Trump is leaving and that will
only further enraged Ahnold Trump if I'm
missing anything let me know